thank you thank you everyone good
morning welcome to this talk just before
we get started I've added a short link
to the content here I'll show you again
later when when we actually need it and
when we're going to start working on the
exercises I see a few people with a
laptop so you might have to work with
your neighbors I'll figure out something
together
so yeah the talk today maintainable
coding in data sense so we'll try to
write data sense code a bit differently
than just just everything in a notebook
and a list of a list of comments there
so I hope you all had some good coffee I
appreciate that it's quite early in the
morning so we'll start with a little bit
of philosophy and try to define well
what do we even mean by maintainable
code does someone want to start with the
definition nobody so I'll give mine
directly it's early so my definition
would be just just this really really
simple by maintainable code the main
thing that we that we expect is that it
will be easy to modify what code has to
be modified all the time so maintainable
code is the code you you hope can be
easily modified that can mean all sort
of things and that's why we all that's
why we'll see a bit later right so one
of their many many principles that exist
in the software development world to to
help with defining what what is
maintainable code one of them is the
single responsibility principle that
just states that any any function or
class that you're writing should really
try to try to do one thing shouldn't you
shouldn't have a good function of good
class that is doing all sort of
multiple things and everything at once
instead it should really it should
really be focusing on one thing and do
it really well and that allows to do all
sort of all sort of nice things with it
later on so that's really what we all
try to keep in mind in this talk but
then in data science it's a little bit
more complicated like there are a lot of
other constraints that appear there
because of the nature of what we're
trying to achieve and that's also what
what we'll discuss here so in order to
do that I'd like to first go through the
domain domain stages of data science
project so you'll have at some point to
process some data to engineer some new
features from from existing existing
data that you've got available you will
have to tune some hyper parameters of
your model to try to find the best in
the best values you will have to train
your model on some data that you have
already pre processed and after you will
have to generate predictions on our new
data so let's go through all those steps
and see what what do we care about what
do we need to care about to make to make
those maintainable so for the first one
process some data where we will care
about is how easy it is to modify to
modify those pre-processing steps so
maybe you want to add some steps maybe
you want to to add scaling scaling step
to your pre-processing pipeline maybe
you want to remove some maybe you want
to modify some maybe you'll have to to
change a little bit the way you get
categorical features out of some complex
complex data so all of those you should
you should be able to do it as easily as
possible
if your code is maintainable then tune
hyperparameters so your data will change
every time you will change your features
and you will you will change your
pre-processing steps you will have to
retune the whole thing so you would hope
that your
your way of tuning the hyper parameters
and finding the finding the best
parameters for your algorithm is quite
easy to run and you can rerun it every
time anything anything changes to get
the best parameters directly and then
retrain your model same thing for
training your model every time you will
change you will change something in the
data or even if you don't change
something yourself the data itself will
change over time so you will have to you
will need a good process to retrain
retrain it constantly and finally which
I think is the most interesting one
generating predictions on new data so
here you will have to do all the same
steps that you've done in your
pre-processing stage on the training
data you'll have to apply the exact same
transformations but ideally without
repeating any code because if you start
repeating code then it becomes much less
maintainable you have to modify things
in two different places at the same time
so how how do you do that that's that's
something we'll see we'll see later in
industry so actually right now so the
first the first thing I'd like to talk
about is how how do you make your you
feature engineering data processing
stage more maintainable so again let's
let's focus a little bit on on what we
what we need to do here so for
pre-processing you will need first to
load some data you will need to split
into some training data some test data
you will probably need to drop some
features you don't need you don't need
everything there you will need to clean
some of them so remove the null values
maybe you'll need to to remove some
outliers as well all sort of operations
like this you need to engineer some
features so that's probably where all
the creative part of the data scientist
job comes in where you take your old
features and you figure out well how can
I convert this this data to have
something that is is more meaningful for
my algorithm you will probably have to
apply
one hot encoding on the catechol
features unless you use an algorithm
that is that support categorical
features and that's usually one of the
big problems and you also have to
sometimes depending on the algorithm you
use scale and transform the numerical
features that you've got that's quite a
few quite a few things you can do you
can do on your data so let's see let's
take a closer look maybe at number six
so how how how would you apply all those
steps on both the training set and the
test set so how do you how do you make
sure you don't duplicate code here so
the first idea that would come to mind
would be to create a just create a
reusable function apply that function
and test on the training sets apply that
function and test sets yeah that's good
but what if that transformation needs to
remember a state which is the case for
one hot encoding for example for scaling
and those kind of those kinds of
operations that learn something from the
training data just to make sure we on
the same page with that i've got an
example with with one hot encoding to
make to make clear what i mean by that
so say here you've got this training
data with some countries for for
multiple multiple people and then you
apply one hot and coding on it so that's
what that's what you get out of it so
country UK for the first row country
italy and then you have ones and zeros
there now if you want to do the same
thing on the test data if you just apply
one hot encoding again so let's say
we've got this this data in in the test
and sometimes you'll have just one
single row that you want to to apply
this transformation on well if you've
got this data in the test and you apply
one hot encoding that's the that's the
output you would get so it would from
scratch learn again the new columns they
it needs to build and build it in the
same order as it
appears in the test data so that here
there is a big mismatch that's something
that you you shouldn't do and it's going
to break your your algorithm so here
that's a good example of when you need
to to have a pre-processing steps that
need to memorize some transformation to
be applied later and that's what that's
where we would have liked instead right
we would have liked the same columns as
the previous as what has been learnt on
the on the training data and mapped to
the new to the new data set so here we
see it actually that the first one the
row friends when wasn't in the training
data we've got the rows row of zeros
which is here where we want great so in
that case we we will need to be held
somehow class that is able to save to
save the state and that's what the the
secular transformers will allow you to
to do and it facilitates all all that
process so there will be really our main
focus for this tutorial look at all
those tools that are provided by Cyclone
that allow you to write to write code in
a more modular way and overcome all
those issues right so some transformers
that you surely have used in the past so
the label encoder the famous when the
who one hot encoder which we've talked
about already that I suppose everyone
has used the standard scalar as well to
do a scaling transformation so all of
those will have the same API the same
interface they will have a fit
method that just learns a transformation
and written and saves it in its internal
States so for a standard scaler it
learns what what is the weights of the
scaling it has to do and then whenever
you call transform it doesn't change
anything
in its internal state it just applies
the same transformation has learned
before on any new data right so that's
this this interface they will reuse
over and over again some other examples
of of transformers so PCA is actually
implemented as a as a transformer with
recycled lands it will have a dot Fitz
method that allows you to learn the
linear combination to go from from your
original features to the principal
components and then when you call dot
transform it doesn't learn anything
again it just applies that
transformation another one days maybe
less known is the feature Union that is
quite useful to build to apply functions
on on some numerical data and get and
get there get a new array with all the
all the outputs for example here feature
Union of PCA and polynomial feature will
look like this I've got a data frame
with some value I apply a feature Union
of PCA and polynomial features and I get
a new data frame with a lot of new
columns that are generated for me some
of them will be the output of the PCA so
here I keep PCA with n components equal
to so I'll keep the two principal
components and then the polynomial
features will just generate all the
polynomial values for each of my columns
in my previous data set so here that's
interesting because I've I've used this
transformer that takes a list of other
transformers as as input and is itself a
transformer that can generate this new
data so here starting combining things
together and that's what we'll do more
and more later in this tutorial
so now I'm able to generate two first
components of PCA and putting the middle
component of your features all at once
then you can also build your own
transformer objects so to do that you
will need to inherit from two different
classes that are implemented for you in
cyclotron so you'll have the transformer
mixing in the base the base estimator so
those just contains some
some hidden methods that scikit-learn
knows to work with needs to work with
your tools and then all you have to do
is implement the fit method and the
transform method and then you can use
you can use this class everywhere you
want as as a transform object so you
could combine it with the Future Union
like we've done here or with all the
other things we will see later if you
need hyper parameters and that will
become really handy later you can just
add an init method in there pass it some
parameters and and use that as a hyper
parameter later right so here that
that's an example I've got this custom
scalar and I have built that as I said
earlier inherits from transformer mixin
and base estimator it has here Fitz
method that is called on some training
data where it computes the median and
the interquartile range of my training
data it memorizes it with the self the
self keyword here and then whenever I
call transform it doesn't need to learn
anything anymore it can take any any
data of with the same number of columns
as my training data and we'll just apply
that transformation here which is
removing the median and dividing by the
interquartile range right so that's
super easy to actually build your own
transformations like this they will
memorize memorize the state whatever
state you need and in the exercise that
we have coming soon we'll will do that
together with some transformations there
a bit that are really really common to
do them on Dana actually the exercises
right now sir so if you go to them so I
can show again this year old
so if you go to that URL that will bring
you to github repository where you've
got all of that including here an
exercise so if you clone if you clone
that repository you can then open what
you want to you all
yeah sorry anyway so once you've cloned
it you can you can then open in the
exercise the exercise notebook that that
is where all the instructions are so
that's not where we're going to write
the code it's where the instructions are
[Music]
gee okay give a minute to do that you're
good with the you I'll take that for yes
so multiple things need to show here so
when you open the notebook so here
you'll have instructions the first thing
we will do here is set set this not work
magic magic method which I don't know if
everyone has used before but it's a
really useful trick if you want to
develop codes in an editor on other in
another place and still load it in the
notebook so here if I run those two
those two comments
they will set the auto reload mode that
is whatever whatever function I import
from a file that I'm writing if I modify
the file itself then the notebook
automatically reloads reloads the latest
version that I've got so I don't need to
restart the notebook every time I make a
modification in my file that allows me
to live updates the update the file in
my editor and see test it and prototype
it in the notebook so you get the best
of the two worlds so if I run that here
which provide a function that loads the
data sets
oops that doesn't work so you need to
install job lip-lip install job Lib
we'll talk about this library later what
it means here
all right here
still nuts anyway I'll just uncommon
that for now is it working for you guys
I'm just gonna come in to what
right so in the meantime was I'm solving
that I can at least explain what the
exercise is so here what I'm fighting to
load is the data set so that's yep and
here I'm just zooming on the arrow I'm
getting sir so here what I'm trying to
do it is well actually I can just load
it with spenders to show you
no but I just killed it
right so
yeah so that's that's what she'd ever
loaded with the comment below and if you
have job Laban and scikit-learn and
installed properly that should work for
all of you so that's the that's the data
I'm trying to load so that's the
Kickstarter data set there is quite a
common one in like machine learning
competitions and things like that so it
contains some information about
Kickstarter campaigns Kickstarter
campaign can be launched on the website
a certain time with certain certain
attributes it so here you've got
information like the description the
name of the campaign they are trying to
launch the goal so they are trying to
raise money so how much money they are
trying to raise you've got things about
from which country they're trying to
raise it in what currency and you also
have the currency exchange rate so you
can actually try to convert from a
currency to another and you've got
information about again the location the
category of the campaign and all sort of
informations like this and what we're
trying to predict is whether that
campaign will be successful or not so
we've got that information in the other
in the other file why train that's app
so here if does that comment run for
everyone else but me great so it's just
meeting perfect so that's the first
thing I wanted to explain and the second
thing is we're providing some first
skeleton for a foreign models
so here what we've decided to do is
divide divide our model into two main
files so you'll have the Transformers
here there will be the place where you
can define all your Transformers objects
so here all the pre-processing steps
that we want to do we are saving them in
this Transformers dot PI as a class with
the dot v dot transform method so all of
those you can we will implement it
together so here you will see that we
one which is categories xtrade extractor
which is supposed to extract a category
from the JSON this one as well yeah all
of them alright so yeah so here this
class here is the transform and I will
allow you to extract some JSON that is
contained in the category information
here so we'll we'll take a closer look
later you've got this one there is a
rule adjuster that allows you to convert
that once we've implemented it will
allow you to convert a goal that is
given as dollars into I mean all the
goals that are given in anything else
than dollars into dollars using the
using the the exchange rate you also
have this other preprocessor transformer
here that will implement that we'll just
load some some dates from the from the
data and compute the difference between
two days to see how many days did the
person live between say the launch of
the campaign and whatever deadline
they're working towards and this one is
a transformative allow you to extract
the country from from the data set and
map it into a more larger area so you
can say for example here we'll group
together all the countries in in Europe
so those are the Transformers they will
they will implement and there is a model
the p/y which is where you'll put all
the things together and so here we've
got that load data set method that was a
function that wasn't working for me that
I'll fix in a second
then you've got a build model a build
model function that real we'll explain a
bit more later and other functions that
are that work as entry points to tune
train your model etc so that's for the
general architecture of our model here
now we'll focus on the Transformers only
so if you take maybe ten minutes should
be enough to go through the part one of
this network that explains how to
implement all those custom all those
custom transformers that I've that I've
talked about so the category extractor
first and as you can see here in a
notebook we only have code to test your
implementation and the implementation
itself is done in in the file so if you
open the file Transformers dot by edit
it's on this side and then go to the
notebook to test your implementation it
should all work perfectly fine right so
take ten five to ten minutes to do that
in the meantime I'm fixing my error
perfect
all right have it working this week and
let me know if you've got any question
so remember as well
the main structure to build your own
your own transformer something important
here is that your fit method even even
if you don't want to do anything in the
fits stage which is the case for the
first the first few transformers we're
building it needs to return itself
that's just what what Sackett learn
expects so if you don't have it return
itself you have some some nasty bugs
later on
all right so let's try to do that
together now so the first one is
category is extractor so as I explained
earlier this one is meant to to read
that field here called category father
that field here called category and
extract a certain category out of it so
first let's let me actually show that
field a bit more so if it X train that
category you can see how it looks like
so that's some some JSON some string in
a JSON format here let me just get the
first one for example
Oh cuz they IDs to do it great
so it's so here should take a look at at
that it will have this feel-good slug
which is the only one we we care about
here that has this information so the
first the first part of the the field
slug will be our generic category for
for the campaign and the second one will
be more precise category so here we
won't act out of this specific column we
want to extract those two this two
fields so let's implement transformer
for that so here we are already
providing two two methods the first one
the init is actually defining a hyper
parameter here that is use all there is
just a trick they added that allows to
decide whether you want to create
whether you want to extract all the
categories or if you want to extract
only categories that you've hard-coded
initially so here the idea is that there
might be so many random categories in
all those JSON fields
so I've pre-selected the main ones that
I was interested in and then I've added
a default for those that I'm not
interested interested in so if you look
at the help of the helper method that
I've written here that basically loads
loads the file loads this string here as
using JSON into a dictionary it's
getting the slug method and then it's
getting the two different the two
different values as a tuple and then
here I'm just saying that if if you're
not specifying the use all parameter you
will only you will filter so if if the
first category is not in your list of
categories you care about then you
return you return a default if your
second category is not in your
list of things you actually care about
you return a default so just a way to
make sure that we don't have that many
we don't have too many dummy features
later on right so now we can implement
our tomatoes that we all need so the fit
methods method here nothing to do we
don't need to learn any any internal
state we just extract the information
from the JSON so here I can just do
return self directly for the transform
so for the transform method I have I get
the data frame and I need to get the
first column category so I'll call
category equal X category so it's easier
to work with and then I need to return a
new a new data frame out of that so I'll
do return PD data frame and this data
frame needs a column called gen cat for
the generic category and that will be my
category to which I apply I will look
like lambda that takes X and returns
self gets logged so it applies it
basically applies this method on my on
each of the JSON each of the JSON
strings and gets the first value here
right
so it's fetchers do get slug X and I get
only the first value
right so that's here should should work
if I ran that here the first column
works works fine so I can create the
second column which will be the precise
precise how did I decide to call it here
precise cat and that will be the exact
same thing but returning the second
value instead and here if I run that now
I get my two columns right so that's
that's pretty pretty powerful here I've
got a nice class that is easy to
maintain I can add more functionality
there if I want later I can change the
way computing those columns fairly
fairly easily by just modifying my
transform method so it's quite easy to
maintain and as far as I'm concerned in
my top-level
code I'm just calling this this
extractor always the same way because it
always has the same interface so then
the goal adjuster so here that should be
fairly easy wants the same thing I don't
need to do anything with fits so I can
do return self here to transform I just
need to return a data frame that has
adjusted goal and the address table will
be X
[Music]
so there will be let me check
so there will be the where's it deadline
no not really
oh is it the goal where's the book the
goals there will be X that goal x static
used the rate right so that should do if
I run that again again what I was
expecting
so I think you you get the point with
with those for the time transformer here
that that one is actually it does a bit
more work so I'm just gonna copy paste
the others from the solution directly so
it's faster
right so for the time transformer we
load all our dates into a date/time
object here you see that we actually
multiplying the timestamp by a constant
value because they were not given in in
the right format so that allows you to
get three timestamp objects the
deadlines the created date and the
launch date and then we can start
creating a bit more creative features so
that's that's some nice feature
engineering here where we say well what
we care about really is how much time
there was between when we launched the
campaign and in the deadline that you
had so here we can easily compute it as
number of days and same thing how much
time you spent between when you created
the page and and the launch time of your
campaign so let's look at this one so
that returns two nice columns with that
that information and then the last one
which is if you if you wanted to group
together some countries in as as groups
for example so here I've created a map
where I'm saying well all those
countries should go in the following
groups and that's a fairly simple one
where we spend as I'm just calling the
dot map method to to map all of those
together so here country transformer it
returns returns if I do dot sample the
battery and here you've got all the
other groups right so that's for custom
transformers next we will look at a bit
more advanced thing so one one really
cool thing that was added in second
learn
21 so the latest version is the column
transformer so how many of you have used
it before already
okay so it's it's really useful and so
it allows you to to map different
transformers to different to to the
columns that you're interested in so
that allows you to say well this
specific transformation should be
applied to say all my numerical columns
this specific transformation should be
applied to all my cat Oracle columns and
that allows you to start creating rules
on what transformation should be applied
to what part of your data frame so
here's an example we've defined some
numerical columns so the agent celery
some categorical columns the country and
the gender for example and we create a
new object we say that's a column
transformer it takes a list of tuples
and in that tuple you'll have three
different elements the first one is the
name you want to give it the second one
is the actual transformation and the
third one is the list of columns to
apply it to so here I'm saying well I
want to apply PCA not on my whole data
frame but only on those numerical
columns and I want to apply one hot
encoding on only those those columns so
that's really powerful if you combine it
with what we've seen before so you can
start building transformations and
decide then to put them all together in
one single object that map's them to
different parts of your of your data
frame so using all of that you're able
to build a master processor object that
those all the transformations at once
and memorizes all the states that it
needs to so that's a more visual example
here where we're doing doing the same
thing as I explained so we apply PCA on
numerical columns only that's where we
get in a new data frame and we apply one
heart and coding on the catechol columns
only and then the column transformer
will just work as a normal transformer
so once you've created that object you
can call dot fit on some training data
it will learn the the internal state for
all the transformations that you've
you've provided inside it then dot
transform will apply that on any new
data so of course you can do it on your
training data but you can do it on
some test data that you want to process
or later on you can do it on some new
data that you need to generate
predictions for on the fly so it's a
really nice very nice tool another one
pipeline there is older allows you here
not to do things in parallel like the
column transform will do but sequential
operations so for example you might want
to scale some data first and then apply
some pca transformation on it so
pipeline you'll just call the pipeline
object again pass a list of tuples where
you define what what is it that you want
to do so here i want to create a an
object called scalar that scales my data
and then pca so here all those
transformations will be done one by one
on all the all the other columns that
you've got available in your in your
data so that fit on the data then the
transform that's how it will look like
so if you combine those two you can
already anticipate that you can start
building pretty pretty complex pipelines
by having this pipeline that those
sequential operations and then the
current transformers allows you to map
it to specific specific columns only
yeah so it can be used together with the
column transformer so here that's an
example of that here we're going to
steps so we're first creating a pipeline
object that we want to use only for our
numerical features so that pipeline
object is for scaling the data then
applying some pca transformation on it
so that our first transformer and then
we build a top-level column transformer
object that applies this specific
transformation that we've we've created
on the numerical features only and then
for the categorical features it applies
one hot encoding right so you can start
building more complex more complex
transformers this way
so the great thing here is really this
the second point is that you you're
making everything really really modular
like every every sort of operation every
functionality of your code will be a
separate class specific transformer that
does something something specific really
well you can test it later and then you
you're just building pipelines by
combining them together so that's allows
you to keep your code quite quite clean
here the only thing we are missing so
far is the predictive the predictive
model part of of our code well actually
that's not completely true because
pipeline can be used for for
transformers but it can also be used
combined with a predictive model so if
you use as a last step of your pipeline
not a transformer but an actual model
that has a dot predict method the
pipeline will automatically inherit that
that predict method and be able to
generate predictions on your on your
data directly so that means that you can
you can do something like that so you'll
have your processor that we've mentioned
before which here is a column
transformer object that does something
on the numerical columns and do
something on the catechol columns and
then we put that inside another pipeline
that has a preprocessor stage so that's
your that's your your first your first
level here and then the second level
which is whatever algorithm you want so
here we've chosen a decision tree the
great thing about that is that your
model isn't isn't just an algorithm
anymore and all your all your hyper
parameters are not just on your model
anymore so it's not just about choosing
the best parameters for your decision
tree it's about choosing the best
parameters for all your pre-processing
steps together with with your final
algorithm the decision tree here
so maybe changing the values that you
have in your the components that you
keep in your PCA will affect the best
parameters to choose in your decision
tree so it's normal to have all of those
tuned together and trained together so
here that allows you to do that to
represent a model as not just an
algorithm but a bunch of pre-processing
steps plus an algorithm at the end and
that also that's also really good to
avoid data leakage because you you have
all the steps run on any batch of data
you provide so if you're doing
cross-validation all the pre-processing
steps everything will be done only on
that single batch that you're providing
instead of leaking some information
potentially from other batches if you
did the pre-processing before the
cross-validation and you can easily
apply that pipeline to any new data once
you've managed to train it it's just a
matter of calling dot predicts and it
will go through all the pre-processing
steps plus the predictive the predictive
part and finally yeah it's more modular
so it will be much easier to test and
maintain so we've got an exercise for
this as well which should be fairly
short so maybe let's take five minutes
for you to take a look so here it will
be in the model dot buy file where we've
defined functions that that puts all our
transformer objects together so here the
first one the most important one is the
function that builds the model so it
basically so here two first steps that
we're providing it creates a pipeline
for categories that we've extracted with
that categories extract object so where
does is that it first calls transformer
and then it calls the one hot and cutter
to create dummies out of that and we
also have another pipeline that is for
the country
the Contra transformer so same thing
it's just
creating dummies out of the catechol
features so those are just the steps
that are provided then the exercise here
is to create a column transformer object
that has all the steps all the steps we
want so it will have this one the it
will have the category processor it will
have the country processor it needs to
have as well the other the time
transformer and the gold adjuster yep so
yeah if you take a look for the next
five minutes and then the growth rate
you
all right so let's let's do that that
part together now so the first the first
step here is to create your your main
column transform an object will they
will basically put everything together
at this stage so we'll just create a new
column transform how I even imported it
yep
so I'll do preprocessor column
transformer so here I need a list of
tuples so the first one will be for my
categories so here I will just apply the
cats processor and I've got a list of my
categorical also here this one is just
the column category right so here my
categories I actually extracted from
from only the category category column
so if I provide this processor this
transformer object only the category
column that should be enough then I will
need countries there will be my country
processor and I just need the column
country there then I will need to use
this what else I got the goal adjuster
that needs the goal column and the
static USD rate column so I'll call that
how do they call it the solution that
call it goal so there will be the goal I
just herbs go register and that will
need
the goal column and Static USD rate and
finally I want as well the time
transformer so here I'll call that all
the time yeah called time fly the time
transformer and I will need those two
columns the stay columns the deadlines
created that and launch that deadline
creating that just right so oops still
missing one thing so that's for a free
processor object so now I've got my
pre-processing stage now I need to put
it together with some predictive model
so I'll just call it a cold model there
will be a pipeline where I basically
have two stages so pre processor will be
my pre processor I'd define just above
that's my first stage and then my second
stage will just be some algorithm sir
let's call it model and here I think
I've already imported the decision tree
somewhere yeah so let's just do decision
tree decision tree classifier with just
default default parameters for now cuz
we're gonna churn it anyway so did I do
something wrong
is it going to work doesn't work I need
to return it that would be good
all right category stand or category
there is category list
and it check
oh yeah I need to pass a [ __ ] okay
that's my foot
need to pass everything is a list here
okay
right and now it's working so that's
that's pretty cool here because we we've
got all all our Moodle now can be built
with this single function and we can
return a new instance of our model
including all the steps that it needs
with one single one single function so
here that's quite easy to change to
change the pipelines if I want to the
last step creates a preprocessor
preprocessor with older all the things
all the features that I need to build
and the really last one puts it together
with some algorithm so here from from a
top-level point of view I just need to
instantiate a new model calling that
function I can fit it on some on some
data and then I call predict and it
works just like any any algorithm even
though it has all the people sing steps
included to it right so next let's go
back to slides right so now we've got
about everything and with everything we
need to to build the model and we're
ready to start thinking about training
it and tuning it and all of those so
here the first thing that we need to we
will need to to think is how when we're
training our model that's something that
can take a while and when we're
generating predictions we need somehow
to be able to load a model that we've
trained we've trained previously so here
we will want to be able to save somehow
that model on disk and be able to out
train model on disk and be able to load
it later to use it say if you want to
use it on put in production just to
generate predictions you don't want to
retrain it every time so here
that's what model persistence will mean
so they're two main ways of doing it
with with button of sterilizing objects
you have pickle that is quite quite well
known and job Lib there is a bit less
known today pretty much pretty much
equivalent in terms of performance in
their documentation job Lib says that
they tend to be more efficient with with
larger arrays so we might prefer that
for working with benders and in gnome
pies with object that work we spend as
and don't buy something cool with job
Lib is that the interface is just a bit
easier to use so that's how that's how
you pickle your model using the pickle
library so you'd have to open the file
in binary then dump it and then open the
file again in binary and load it if you
wanted to do that with job Lib it's just
a bit easier because they abstract from
you the loading the file in binary mode
so you can just drop lib dump here
you've got your model so that's your
single single object pipeline that has
been trained that has you you have gone
teed there it has everything you need in
it and then you specify your file and it
will just dump the whole object on that
file and then later on if you want to
load it it's really easy you just call
dot load and past the path that you want
to load just keep in mind it has some
limitations so people and table will
just be Co that specific object that
you're specifying which is why actually
it's important to to have one single
object but it does not save the
dependencies so it will not you will
still need the code that's that it
relies on to to run so that means all
the libraries that it's calling but also
your custom your custom classes
everything you will need the files to be
able to run it also the data is not
saved so if like you need to retrain
your model you also need to make sure
that you have snapshots of of your data
other other thing to keep in mind when
you're using those libraries is that the
versions are really really important so
since it's relying on whatever whatever
libraries you've got installed when
you're loading the model if it has been
saved with different versions then it
can often have half some prime so it's
really important here that you you're
keeping track of what versions you've
pick your mode always and make sure that
whatever environments you load the
people from will have the exact same
versions and dependencies installed and
the last the last comment here is that
yeah you can pickle anything any any
object in Python so make sure that you
don't load some people that has been
provided by some in some places that you
don't trust because it could contain
anything including including some
scripts that mess up everything so keep
that in mind
so we've got an exercise for that where
we are going to here implement the last
so we only need three things now for our
model to be able to run it to run it on
the command line so we need a method to
tune it we need a method to train it and
we need a method to test it so we've got
all of those all of those here so let's
let's yeah we got time so let's take
another five minutes to look at that
should be so here it should be fairly
easy you only need two for tuning for
example you will need to call your your
your function that builds a new instance
of the model that gives you a new
instance then you need to you can use
grid search directly on it so grid
search support supports the suppose the
pipeline the pipeline objects so here
what we have
is defined in a conflict that by file
your great parameters so you can
uncomment that or just come up with your
own parameters that you want to tune so
here for example we're saying that we
want to change the max depth of the
model stage of the pipeline so here the
max depth of the model stage will be the
max depth of our decision tree we want
to tune the min sample split of that
decision tree as well so model
underscore underscore the name of the
attribute in the decision tree and then
we also want to attune some of the some
of the parameters of preprocessor object
so here are preprocessor object we can
change use all from false to true so
those are a few example if I do that
actually I can just give you tip so if
you do model that get params that gives
you all the parameters that are in your
pipeline object in your model so that
till it tells you all the steps that
you've got - a zoom in a bit more all
the steps that you've got there so it's
quite a big one if you do that keys it
tells you all the parameters that you
can that you can tune that you can tune
there so that's where you see that so
you've got the things on your where is
it you've got all the parameters that
are on on your model so like class
weights so all of those are defined on
on my decision tree so I can tune all of
those but I can also tune everything
that is defined on my preprocessor so
that's the that's the one that I've
chosen to tune here right so you can
access all those parameters and provide
them in the in the grid search actually
it's maybe better if I just do it
straight away all right so that's that's
just do it together so here first step
for tuning the tuning the model is well
load the data
so a lot ex train why train load data
set to have the data set here no it's
not data set data set and I want to load
okay I'll just copy the part from here
extreme weight okay right so first I
load the training data then I'm creating
instantiating a new model so I'll do
build model and then I can call grid
session so have I loaded the growth
research yes I have it there so I can
define a new grid search object here
there will be GS equal grid search CV I
pass my model directly I will pass the
parameters that I've defined in config
so I'll first uncommon them they said we
want to reduce okay so now I go here I
imports all of those great poems and I
can start using them
okay here I'll do CV equal say three and
underscore jobs equal minus one then I
do GS fits on extra in white rain and I
can just print Vasco will be so here you
don't necessarily want you to print
maybe you want to actually get those
parameters and automatically retrain
your model with those parameters but
keep things simple I just do it like
this
vesko let's see if that works here so if
I call that know I need to imports as
well
extreme white rain right it's nice tunic
my model
and here it's telling me the best guy
can also add it to tell me the best
parameters best poems chilling again
the night tells me as well what are the
best parameters that I've got in not in
my algorithm only but in my whole in my
whole pipeline so it's telling me that
actually I should use max depth of 9 of
9 and those parameters for the decision
tree but also it's answering my question
I had at the beginning of this tutorial
which was should I use all all the
categories that I get from the data
frame from the category column or should
I use only a subset of those well he is
telling me that I should use all instead
with those parameters of the tree so
that's that's quite nice that allows you
to add some extra parameters to to tune
in there so we'll do the same for
training so for training we'll need
those two first then we'll do a model
that fits X train y train so that's
quite simple here and then the the last
step is to save it onto a file so we'll
do a job Lib dump
we'll save just have one single object
to say which is our model and let's give
it a name model job Lib so here I do not
have a model dojo blip yet so I can see
if it worked if I run that extreme train
if I run that oops still not import job
lab no good I commented out creating
traps for myself and I strained it and
you see that it has saved it here what's
binary file so I can't open it but it
has saved it on this so I'm able to load
it later and actually that's the next
exercise loading that and generating
predictions so here test model I'm just
going to load directly
but all the job lab that would be my
model then I need to load some data as
well so I'll use that here but it's not
extreme its X test by test and I need to
import that as well at the top right so
once I've got that now I can easily just
compute accuracy score classification
report anything I want I just do white
bread will be equal to model that
predicts next tests and then I can just
do prints accuracy will be format Y
tests white bread you can try that here
that's the wrong one here it is right so
here my bad accuracy let's go alright
right so now I'm also able to easily
test test my model and I can add
classification report to that if I want
nope
okay right and now I've got the
classification report as well right so
that's that's quite nice now I've got
pretty much all the code
I need properly modular and separated so
I can easily make modifications so I can
modify the existing transformers that
I've got here in this file by changing
the way say I'm computing the category
or I'm computing anything here I just
need to focus on the transform method
inside my class if I want to add an
extra step I just create a new
transformer I can test it individually
making sure it works fine and then in
the model dot PI I just need to add it
here in the build model as an extra step
so either I have to create a pipeline
object or I added directly to my
top-level column transformer if I want
to change the algorithm I'm using it's
quite easy as well to do here and then
I'm just modifying the parameters that I
want to tune to correspond to to my to
my both algorithm and and steps and it's
all I can do all of that together here
so also providing some command line tool
out of that because it's easier to just
run it directly from the command line
instead of having to start the shell and
call the commands the functions yourself
so here we've just defined rounded by
that those basically imports are three
main entry points so that thun model
train model and test model and then just
use the arc pass library in order to to
have that as arguments on the command
line so if I test that now did you see
the exercise and yes i zoom in here if I
do Titan rounded pie stay tuned they
will turn my model as it says
and tell me what the best parameters are
maybe yeah so here you can reach unity
easily so every time you make a new step
you're changing the steps and you're in
your code you actually don't have to go
through the notebook anymore you can
just run it here and see how that
improve how that improved your your
cross-validation score and how what what
are the best parameters that you should
use when you train your final model I
can also do train if I want to train my
model again and save it as a job Lib
cellulous file and then whenever I run
the test I can see the final final value
of my score classification report
anything I'm interested in really and we
could implement another another entry
point that would be for predict that
could be predicting loading the
serialized the sailors model and
generate predictions on any any new data
that you provided so that would be that
would be the command you would use if
you use that model in production right
so if you a few comments things that I
have skipped a little bit so first it's
quite important so we're going to be
loading data that will they will change
sometimes you will have large training
data sets sometimes you'll have a single
row
so here it's missus it's it can be quite
risky to to just rely on pandas
inferring what type what types your
columns should be so it's really
important to whenever yoga you you want
to make it to make maintainable version
of your of your of your codes to use to
fix the tea types so that's where we've
done here we've just specified the D
types for all the columns and whenever
we actually loading the data with that
function that's why I've provided that
function here we make sure that every
time we load the data base if
the same the same d-types that way we
sure that something won't break because
some some data has been loaded has been
inferred as a different type than it was
important to have a requirements that PI
as well so the text sorry since we here
we are cellulite in our model and we
expecting our model to work for to work
in the in the future and support to make
sure we can replicate exactly the same
the same environment over and over again
so requirements the text with the actual
versions of the library will help you
doing that yeah if you're making
incremental changes make sure you you're
checking the the disco in the tuning
steps of the cross-validation score and
not the not disc on the test set because
that would obviously be massive massive
massive of overfitting to do that so
just do all your feature engineering
using the the tuning cross-validation
score and yeah the really cool thing is
that this this is quite modular so you
can easily write tests so that means you
really should now it's it's it's quite
straightforward actually to just take
this all those transformers in isolation
and build build test for it and actually
that's what that's what the next section
is about yeah and with all of that
hopefully you're updating your test
should be your model story so it should
be less stressful just yet to finish we
we have a booth somewhere tomorrow so
just come say hi
[Applause]
five minutes for questions you have any
yep oh yeah you could use numpy so it it
relies on so the question was does it
work only with spenders or with non pay
as well so yeah it since like all of all
of the Transformers from from psychic
learn except either numpy array or
PEMDAS array here turns out that the
actual transformers that I've built
I'm using some some pandas method so my
own code will not work with spenders
with oh yeah you need to specify the
column there yes so it's not it's not
this one it's not going to work with
with number because it's relying on you
specifying what column it should be but
the rest should do yeah any more
questions yeah so with the pickle or the
other one was called
yep so you mentioned a couple of
limitations is there any other way to
store circuit in your model the model
yeah so you say I want to I turn a model
and then they pass that to someone else
so here did that that's actually the
recommended way on on scikit-learn on
their documentation they're using so
they don't have a custom way of doing it
they're using pickers and job Lib which
are like just generate by then once if
you wanted to store that just just just
the data then does has a binary formats
that are that they're using so you could
do that but the model itself
not really
cool coffee time then
[Applause]